[Music]
all right let's go to chris
in denver what's up chris hey dr deed
thanks for taking my call how you doing
today you got it brother what's going on
man
um i'd love to chat with you about um
how to work through
feeling guilty and maybe even some
imposter syndrome
as it relates to my career as i compare
it to my parents
and the income they made growing when i
was growing up huh
tell me about it great question i get
this question a lot man so
i'm glad you're we're connecting here
yeah i appreciate it you've been a great
addition to ramsey and i feel like the
mindset part of of finance is super
important so
i'm happy to happy to have you help me
help or you help me
whatever we're trying to do here there
you go um so so growing up i
grew up pretty blue collar my dad worked
three jobs he would be a mailman all day
after that he'd be a landscaper after
that he'd be a bartender he'd get home
at 2 a.m
and then right back at it the next day
and he busted his butt to to be where he
was and to raise us
and and now i have a really good job i
make a lot of money and i i don't work
nearly as hard as he does and uh
i don't know i kind of struggle with
that and they still struggle they still
you know barely make ends meet and i'm
you know living a good life and
they wouldn't accept my help even if i
wanted to so i don't know it's just uh
it's a lot what do you feel guilty
i'm more emotional yeah i'm more
emotional talking about it than uh
than i thought it would be no it's hard
man i appreciate you
being honest and vulnerable i know
millions of people
i don't know them but there are millions
of people in your exact same situation
that have found themselves in a
different life setting than they grew up
in
and they don't know what to do with it
and they thought this new setting would
solve their problems would
make them feel a certain way and it
doesn't and that feels there's a
disconnect there right
so um
man there's a lot here what makes you
uncomfortable about
being successful
um i just was never raised with money
like
i never asked my parents for you are
giving money a lot of power where does
that power come from
probably insecurity about not having a
lot growing up okay
and so money was supposed to solve
everything why hasn't it solved
everything
um i don't know it's a great question
i mean i'm happy in my life it's it's
just when i look back towards my parents
that
they don't have that and i feel bad so
can i ask you like a
i'm gonna phrase this in a way that's
gonna set you up is that cool okay cool
um who gave you permission to judge your
parents
no one who gave you the right
to look at your parents and say wow
they're missing out they should have
x y or z they could be happier if they
only had x y or z
because you have x y or z and you're not
happier
yeah is there a chance that they're
doing okay
yeah i mean they're doing fine yeah
and so what is it about you having money
that makes you feel like
they could or should or might have
um i've just seen them make some
interesting financial decisions that
i think if they had money they wouldn't
have done that's fair and by interesting
you mean terrible
ridiculous stupid uh your word's not
mine
yeah they're not my parents man i don't
have to defend them good for you though
um so here's here's
my dad's a cop growing up and then he
quit being a cop
halfway through my life and became a
minister at a local church
okay we didn't have a lot growing up
and what i found and this is not
something that my dad did this is
something that somehow i
internalized i divided the world up
into us's and thems
and when you live a life of stress
whenever your body sounds the alarms
when you go into fight or flight it
quickly has a mechanism by which it
divides up who's on my team and who's
not
and we're gonna run or go to war with
those who are not on our team and we're
gonna double down on those who are on
our team
if you look at our country over the last
30 or 40 years one of the things that
media has done
so well particularly advertising is
when they tap into the fight-or-flight
part of your brain
you feel like you need to go do a thing
to get a thing or to go to a thing
what does that mean in brass tacks it
means you go buy stuff to make yourself
feel better
okay or you go to war and how do you go
to war you go buy some more stuff we
need some more gear some more this some
more of that
or you escape you go on vacations right
and so
companies have a vested interest in you
staying buzzed up
and then you look at the political
landscape 50 years later
and i don't care who you vote for chris
but there's some things that the people
you vote for
you're like ah that's probably a bit
much right
but yeah since you're in an us in them
you start biting off things that the
us's are doing
you don't even agree with because it's
not them right so i'm telling you that
to tell you
if you grow up in a blue-collar world
there is some part of your life that is
absorbed into
this is who we are and this is who they
are whoever they
is and all of a sudden you look up with
a great job and a great salary in a big
house and you realize
oh no i'm a vey yeah and then what you
have to do
is either convince yourself that the
uses that you grew up with were wrong
and we got to burn it to the ground and
i got to fix them and help
them or help the us's become one of
these
right yeah or
you live this gapped life where
so my last job in texas um
i was i put in for a promotion i didn't
get it and i didn't know why i did i was
even
i wasn't even um considered right they
didn't give me an interview for it and
so i asked a buddy who was ahead of me
on this on the hierarchy
and he said man people think you're a
politician it's like what are you
talking about
i said man you always hang out with the
cops in the back of the room you always
hang out with the caterers
and you're in there in a suit it looks
like you're just glad-handing and i said
man that's where i feel most comfortable
because i don't feel comfortable hanging
out with the academics i don't feel
comfortable hanging out with the
administrators he looked at me and said
you're an academic administrator my
brother you have ph
two phds you're looking you are now
being the jerk you've been trying to
avoid and that hit me because he was
right
you know what i mean i was pretending
and so here's what i would tell you
be really grateful for what you got
and i am don't feel like you've got to
live in both worlds
okay be a person who treats everyone you
come into contact with
with gratitude with kindness
make sure you acknowledge the mailman
right because you know how that life is
and
love love love your old man he's a grown
man he can make the choices that he
wants to make
and they're not for you to judge right
but he's a guy for you to love
and have you learned tell me
i
you are i'm trying to say this in a
graceful kind way
i uh man
you can just say it well
i can but man i don't want to get
cancelled so here's the deal
if we look over the last 100 years
in our country in the western world the
stock market has done what
gone way up way up it's gone way up we
all got rich
and i noticed people listening to this
like i'm not rich you are you are
and also what has gone up is
diseases of despair addiction cancers
strokes heart attacks um
people in jail so it's come at a cost is
what i'm saying
all sorts of social ills have come at
the cost of us getting
wealthy and i'm not saying that getting
wealthy is bad or evil or wrong
it's not the pursuit
single-mindedly of it is killing us
and so what i would challenge you do you
live by your old man
no i don't how close are y'all
2 000 miles oh dang gina okay that's a
long way so how often do y'all talk
uh once a week i come home like a
handful of times a year
cool so here's what i want you to do
something
one of two things are going to be weird
and cheesy all right
and just shake it off and get over it
cool
yep yes okay great
hey listen when we hang up i know you're
not going to do either of these but i
just want to tell you it will be awesome
if you do
okay so all right here we go i want you
to
ask your old man dad
i want to start reading a book with you
you're smarter than me and wiser than me
you have been to people's houses for
30 or 40 years you've met with people
bartending like and you have done
landscape you've done it all
i don't know what makes your head tick
and i want to learn about things that
you like
so i want to start reading a book with
you old man
you read the book i'll read it and then
we'll talk about it
and if he won't do that some dads don't
read that's fine y'all can watch a show
i want you to start having a shared
experience together where you're going
to talk to one another
and in that discussion you can either
email
if you're really gangster you can write
letters but i want you to
create some sort of exchange dialogue
with your dad we all write back and
forth
back and forth to each other often men
are terrible
myself included at sitting down with
other men and just talking about hey
what's going on in your life how's it
going
man those are skills that i'm
consistently trying to learn
um but writing man i've seen writing get
to the souls of men in ways that just
chitchatting won't so commit to writing
back and forth whether it's about a book
whether it's about a show whether it's
about fill in the blank
back and forth and back and forth and
back and forth and here's what i'm
trying to get at
i want you to take money out of the
relationship with your dad your dad's
made choices that your dad made man
he made choices that he made your
choices to
have a um a better life are number one
built on his hard work ethic number two
built off the the lessons of character
and
um relationship building that only a
bartender and a mailman can pass along
to his son
and number three doesn't matter man
doesn't matter it hasn't made your life
it's it's maybe made your life more
comfortable
but it hasn't fixed that hole in your
heart that hole in your heart can only
be fixed through relationships man
so reach it reach out start
relationships with your dad
and it may not look like that it may be
weird you all may intentionally get
together once every five months now
or i mean once every two months now or
three months now it's hard when you're
2000 miles away i get that
could be a facetime conversation once a
week i mean you're talking about awkward
those would be weird man be awkward
and you my brother you started gratitude
journal today
every day write down the things you are
grateful for
don't sentence yourself to a life of
misery because you're financially
successful
give like crazy give
give give be grateful and when you feel
yourself starting to beat yourself up
because
oh yeah i'm a they now and i'm not one
of the us's
it's fine the uses and thems is a fake
category anyway
propagated by every by the air we
breathe nowadays
okay be graceful with yourself be
grateful for your old man and dude
connection connection relationships all
right brother thanks for the call chris